quitting is never an option there's
never a failure unless you quit what's
up believe nation it's Evan I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
today let's learn one of the most common
rules that successful people follow
don't quit also if you want to learn
what tom bill you eric thomas myself and
other entrepreneurs have to say about
building unstoppable confidence check
out my 250 for confidence series where
every day for the next 254 days i will
send you a morning video for free to
help you build your confidence the link
to join is in the description below
you've got to make a sacrifice if you
don't get to the next level you're gonna
have to give up something right there's
a gap between who people are and what
they tell you they want to accomplish if
you're doing work that you love you're
more likely to follow through you're
more likely to do it because it doesn't
feel like work because you love doing it
[Music]
I fail at so many pieces I feel at 13
businesses 13 13 Wow before having what
a court go success right so from 17 to
what age did the decide within three
years so three years 13 businesses in
and about losses all losses or lessons
yeah no all losses haha no it's not as
serious yeah yeah it was Animax on my
credit card
and lost on my mom's face savings yeah I
heard that at one point - you're almost
over a hundred thousand dollars that's
one hundred fifty thousand fifty
thousand dollars and how old are you at
that time 20 20 years old 20 years old
and that was just different loans from
your mom our relatives relatives and my
bra test they wouldn't think my call
anymore yeah yeah it's just I just four
of them everybody that I could did you
burn a lot of bridges at that time to
get I did I did but I always promised
them that just let me let give me one
more chance right but let me try harder
and they believed in me but they just
thought they always thought I was kind
of odd when the family it's like why
don't you just there and just go get a
job but do something like what normal
people yes safe they're safe and do
something like why do you have to have
these crazy ideas he's another idea of
them yeah and I just told them hey
listen if I were just to go get a job
with my I don't even have a college
degree anything like that I would be
making me a man with minimum wage listen
I'm not one hundred fifty thousand
dollars yeah if I was making minimum
wage it would take me forever right to
pay you off to pay you back and pay off
all this debt and to provide for my mom
so like people always look at what I did
oh you must be so motivated there it's
not motivation it was desperation right
it was I had no choice
the transitions going to be hard I'm not
gonna lie to you go from being on the
block going to be a high school dropout
to getting a GED is not the transition
is not easy in order for you to go from
running level to the next level in order
for any woman to transition for any man
to transition the thing that they want
must be greater than the thing they
fairly had you only go to another level
when you own this level and you eat not
a trash cans and you say enough is
enough when you live in an abandoned
buildings in the winter and you say even
up
you only transition from one level to
the next when you tie to the level you
own you keep telling me this happened in
your life and that's happened in your
life and it who is happening to
everybody do you let your pain Punk you
you let your pain make you quit you
thinking special you think you only want
we all go through I'm just gonna give
somehow tomorrow so you gonna have to go
through it just like everybody else you
gonna have to pay the fear sweat blow
tears but guess what when you walk
across that stage it's gonna have that
much more meaningful there's another
kind of instinct that you need to be on
the lookout for and this one is a liar
this one is a saboteur well this one is
a back biter and like the devil himself
he's a shapeshifter
he's gonna disguise himself and make you
think he's got your best interest in
mind
but he doesn't this is the instinct that
says you've had enough this is the
instinct that says you've you've given
it your best shot
you can you can stand down you can back
off you can take a knee
this is the instinct it says you can
rest now do not listen to that instincts
do not listen that instinct is a liar
and wants to bring you down that that's
the instinct that's a defense mechanism
it wants to give you an out
place to run to a little little place of
sympathy an amnesty a little place of
amnesty where everything is forgiven
we're all bees
these failures can gather together and
comfort and drown their sorrows in lies
and in deception and they tell each
other and they'll tell you you did the
best you could know they'll say the dock
the deck the deck was stacked against
you and they'll say it's not your fault
and they'll tell you it's okay to stop
it's okay to settle it's okay to give up
and that is the instinct you need to
fight you need to push back to smash
into the ground do not take the easy way
out do not give up based on instinct if
you are forced to stand down
to retreat so that you can rebuild
Andrea tack so be it but make that
decision based on logic not on the
instinct of surrender and defeat and you
need to train that instinct your
instinct train it to say get up go fight
on and if that is what you become if
that becomes your fundamental reaction
to adversity if that becomes your gut
instinct then you will overcome just
about anything that stands in your path
so I quit my job
comfy corporate job doing really well
for myself and I'm trying to get into
media and so
writing to every big media company with
before my videos and saying please give
me a job like I'll come in like a video
journalist salary I was looking at
salaries that like a quarter of what I
made I was like I don't care about the
money I want to make videos and I want
to spread a message I'm getting
rejection email after rejection email
saying J you never studied media J you
have no background so I'm getting
rejected by all the biggest companies
Business Insider HuffPost The Economist
wired you name it I've got all the
emails and then I try and network with
the editors of these magazines so I find
out where they are I go to the events I
try and talk to them and they liked me
hey man you're like 28 years old why do
you want to do this you make more money
right now hang in the corporate world do
it as a hobby I remember running after
one of our biggest news anchors in
England called John Snow and he rides a
biker in London please like he's huge is
on Channel four one of the biggest
broadcasters for us her and so I've run
off to him when he's on his bike and I'm
like John please please stop and he
stops he's really kind I said John can
you please give me a job I'll just I
don't want to get paid I'll just watch
you and I because he creates these
powerful documentaries he's interviewed
the best of the best like Mandela and
all this time life-changing
conversations and he goes to me he gives
me a card and he goes Jay go get a
masters in media and come back I'm
thinking oh I've spent two three more
years yeah exactly I'm gonna go back
like and hey so I came to a point where
I literally had no other option than to
start a YouTube channel and and my
honest limiting belief at the time was
that doesn't work for anyone and that's
what I said to myself as long as I'm
gonna work for anyone but I literally
had exhausted
I think it's Thomas Edison who says when
you feel you've exhausted every option
remember you haven't and I'd come to
that point where I felt I'd exhausted
every option
apart from starting a YouTube channel so
I launched the channel Jam 3rd 2016 two
years ago and it's doing pretty well
never give up is the best and the worst
advice you can ever give an entrepreneur
the trick is knowing how to use it if
you love what you're doing if you can't
imagine life without this thing that
you're creating even if it's not working
out yet you're not getting the results
yet it's not where you want it to be yet
but you need to know you need it's like
this thing inside you that has to come
out you need to know it was gonna work
or not you could deal with the failure
but you can't deal with not knowing if
that's where you're at with your idea
with your business and you have to keep
going then you can't quit then you have
to find out because otherwise it's gonna
eat you up for the rest of your life if
that's where you're at then you must
find a way to keep going even if that
doesn't make any sense even if you have
to take on part-time jobs even if you
fail in front of everybody you have to
keep going because the regret at age 90
looking back on your life the regret
will be enormous that's how most people
live most people spend their entire life
regretting the things that they didn't
do go look at a retirement home go talk
to your grandparents and
great-grandparents and a lot of them
will be filled with regret I wish I did
this I wish I took my shot I wish I had
the courage I wish I had the bravery to
keep going if that's what you're worried
about then you must you must you must
you must you must you must not give up
and find a way to keep going that's when
it's good advice here's where it's bad
advice
I think people stay in things for too
long as well I think people stay in
their business for too long I think
people say in their relationships are
too long people stay with things because
it's comfortable because they know it
because they recognize it because it's
safe
because it's helping generate some money
they stay in the wrong thing for too
long if you are in the wrong thing then
quit immediately I can't tell you how
many entrepreneurs I come across who've
had some level of success maybe they're
not crushing it but they've had some
level success and then they start to
hate their business they start to get
bored of their business because they
never evolved because they grew as a
human being but their business didn't
grow alongside it and you keep getting
stuck doing the same thing over and over
and over again day in and day out and
you start to hate your business and you
feel like you have to stay
this company because you should never
give up on it no quit get out of that
thing either change either adjust what
you're gonna be doing then come up with
a new product come with the new service
make some tweaks or it's just so far
away from what you're interested in now
then quit try to sell the business if
there's a way out and if not just
abandon ship and go do something else
because this is the most important part
right here this part right now you will
never win doing work that you hate you
will never win you will never have
success you'll never get the goals that
you want doing work that you hate
because the people who love doing that
work will always crush you you can have
the most talent the most skills the most
resources in the world but if you do not
love the work if you do not love the
process you will get crushed you will
get demolished by the people who love it
and you will never be happy you will
always be a junior version of somebody
else and so you have to find the thing
that you are so dead in love with it's
why finding your passion doing the thing
that you love is consistently the number
one most important rule that comes up
over and over and over and over again in
his videos not because I'm sharing it
because all these people have had
success are sharing it and so you will
never win doing work that you hate if
you are loving the work that you're
doing if you have to find out if this is
gonna work or not then you can never
quit then you can never give up then you
have to see it through at least to know
you could deal with the failure but you
cannot deal with not knowing but if you
don't love what you're doing if you
don't love the thing anymore then quit
immediately move on adjust find
something else and know that there's
something great for you out there
and that's why never quit is the best
and the worst advice you can ever give
an entrepreneur if I could count the
amount of times I was told no it would
amount to I mean just there was way too
many times and it made being told yes
that much better and so I created the
mentality in my head of taking no as no
not right now not no this isn't for you
so no didn't have a period it had a dot
dot dot and so if I had given up after
the first time I had said no I wouldn't
be here and so it's just you know not
letting someone dictate your future if
you believe in something so strongly and
you want to do something so strongly
who's going to tell you to not do
so that was adapting that kind of
allowed me to take a lot of pressure off
too why the point of having a seal live
with you this is this book called living
with the seal 31 days training with the
toughest man on the planet and I watched
a few videos and this guy is a freak but
why did you decide to to have him live
with you when he first moved in the
first he comes into the house and he has
a little knapsack for 30 days if I go
away for 30 days I'm checking two bags
all right he has this little like Huck
Finn from 30 days had all his clothes
and everything and his whole life in the
bag and I said to him his name is David
Goggin so if you're listening and you
know him where you want to google him I
said in the book I refer to him as seal
but now you know he's out there so he
came to the house I said to him you know
hey here's your room you know I'll show
you around make yourself at home and you
know my home is your home for the next
thirty days and he said no huh-uh
he said I don't have a home and I said
no make yourself at home it's an
expression
and he said I don't operate in
expressions Wow and that was sort of
like okay let's start that was kind of
our opening act no settling here no yeah
and then we went down to the gym five
minutes into the into our 31 day journey
and he said I want to see how many
pull-ups you can do so I said all right
so I guess to kind of get a level of
like where I was that and I am not as
strong sure guy so I didn't maybe eight
pull-ups and then I dropped down and he
said all right wait 30 seconds into it
again do it again
so I waited 30 seconds got back up on
the bar I did like six he said alright
one more time and now like I'm starting
to feel it you know a guy I don't think
I can even get back up on the bar and I
get I get three but three like you know
kicking my chin over like whatever I
could do to get over the bar so I said
alright what's next he said what's next
is we're gonna stay here till you do 100
more Oh Mike and I said even one at a
time yeah and I'm like come on man I
could like that's great on paper but I
physically can't do a hundred more and
that was our start of many lessons that
I learned because I ended up doing it
one at a time and what he taught me was
there's so many of our limit
patience are self-imposed mm-hmm you
know and we sets we set something up in
our brain we program our brain one way
and that's our limit and until we can
get past that and see what we're really
made of and like get uncomfortable and
experience pain mm-hmm you can't real
you don't really don't know what you're
capable of yeah so that was a really
good good lesson for me and every day
was a lesson like that if you ever felt
like there were times where you wanted
to quit all that music wasn't
necessarily for you like you didn't have
faith in what you were doing
yeah that's good no no because uh
quitting isn't never an option
but have there been times where you've
made me felt like you talked about being
misunderstood before have there been
times where you've maybe felt like
people weren't understanding it and then
that frustration easy to maybe not want
to continue on that path they give me as
they give me going mm-hmm that type of
[ __ ] right there
I'm not being accepted it's like my or
my whole driver like people enough I
mean I just want to prove a point I'm
not as bad as I just want to know what
you don't with you know and that's
always helpful information and I get
that advice to everybody like you're so
on if you feel like quitting is the
thing just trying to quit into like that
extra pump second win
have you ever done a trip that didn't
work almost every single one in front of
people failed something well the good
news about doing magic is and I think
like rappers - it's like you never know
where the end is because it's up to him
so it's you you can keep improvising and
going so there's never a failure unless
you quit so if you keep going there's
not a failure you just keep changing and
moving
because you believe water but you can't
make them drink you see I can tell you
it's a presentation but if you walk down
these doors you don't buy what you see
I'm not something certainly you know you
haven't changed
I'm concerned with the process because a
lot of people are surprised but not many
people work the process a lot of people
have the world win but few people have
the will to prepare to it the processes
were important the process
[Music]
[Music]
with plenty powers of previous people's
to give up the only thing about life and
destination maybe they go with a dream
whatever it is that you aspire to do
with your life the one thing that could
sell you right now with a black anything
special but the one thing I can
guarantee people don't believe you with
this if you don't give up if you don't
stop if you don't give it nothing to
beat you nothing will come for you
nothing will stop never give up never
stop never doubt yourself listen to me
there's always hope there's always
somebody inside now I've got a really
special bonus clip from tom bill you on
how to allow yourself to dream that I
think you're going to really enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
taking action in your life or in your
business and if you're feeling bold
leave the answer to these questions in
the comments below here we go question
number one what dream are you not
willing to quit on number two when you
doubt yourself what will you do and
number three who can hold you
accountable to your commitment
never give up on what you really want to
do the person with big dreams is more
powerful than the person with all the
facts H Jackson Browne
truer words have never been spoken it is
one of the most interesting things about
the human condition
that all of the facts in the world no
matter how true something may
objectively really be the only thing
that matters is whether or not you've
got the energy to see through to the end
of what you want to do and the energy
comes not from truth the energy comes
from your dream the energy comes from
what it is that you want to do the
energy ultimately is born out of what
you want to create it's born out of a
willingness to allow yourself to dream
it's born out of a willingness to think
that you actually can do it it's born
out of a willingness to take that first
step but the only reason that you're
gonna take that first step is you
believe that you can actually make your
dreams come true and that sense of this
thing that you have in your mind that
you can make it real that you can bring
it into the real world and have that
excitement you've long fantasized about
and understand and really feel in your
gut that that thing that you've dreamed
about can be real and when you have that
that's when you're going to have the
energy that you need to push and to
fight and to go through all of the
difficult things that you're gonna have
to to get on the other side and make
that dream real as Ferdinand Fox said
the most powerful weapon on
is the human soul on fire but the human
soul can't be on fire without a dream a
human soul is not fed by facts a human
soul is fed instead by a belief that it
can accomplish what it wants to
accomplish it's fed by that thing that
idea that you found in your mind that
you fan those flames of interest and
turned it into a real fascination and
fan those flames further into excitement
and allowed yourself to truly embody
that belief that you can make it happen
so right now whatever it is whatever
crazy dream you have it we all have one
stop judging yourself for it stop
telling yourself you can't do it and
understand you cultivate that fire when
you take that little ember and you fan
it into a raging in front of the that
thing that human stole on fire is what's
going to allow you to build something
that the world has never seen before but
it starts with that dream it starts with
your willingness to cultivate that to
think about it to allow yourself to do
that because so many people stop
themselves they think they're inadequate
they think that they can never do it
is from fact
it's not something that's gonna help you
live a life that excites you it's not
something that's gonna help you excite
other people for one thing that will do
that is the dream so right now allow
yourself that simply to dream the most
important word ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple that would be
like a little beacon if you want to
learn from Eric Thomas on how to develop
discipline to pursue your dreams check
out the video right next to me I think
you're gonna enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there many of
you are getting distracted because you
don't have something that's over to
distraction
shut the TV down let's do it